all right
[Applause]
happy Wednesday everyone
I got a haircut I got a haircut all
right
so the covid-19 public health emergency
officially ends tomorrow I can finally
stop washing my hands
but how about the polio scare is that
still in play isn't that typical of
government 750 days late in a trillion
dollars short but it's a huge relief for
New Yorkers we can return to wearing
masks just to block the smell of urine
yeah
still for the most of us that stuff
ended a long time ago when we decided to
stop living in fear and get back to
doing the things that we love
you
but the end of the emergency also brings
with it the end of title 42.
no not level 42.
[Music]
they're right up there with the Beatles
the insects
but title 42 allowed us to deport
migrants caught crossing the border and
deny them Asylum for public health
reasons you know as if letting millions
of unvetted foreigners pour into your
backyard isn't already a threat to your
health
it is amazing the concern for their
coveted status that's what it was for
not fentanyl poisonings or sex
trafficking or gang shootings but those
who got booted didn't face any charges
so they just tried again
but now that policy ends and everyone's
bracing for thousands more migrants you
know migrants used to mean people that
were passing through now they're harder
to remove than Dianne Feinstein
yeah tell me about it she's been staying
with me for months
I wonder if it remains to be seen as if
it's going to be chaotic for a while
so but it remains to be seen it's going
to be chaotic for a while
thank you Captain Obvious
I'm pretty sure his Visiting Angel was
holding cue cards
Visiting Angels I love that song but
does it matter it's Point America's
expectations for Biden are lower than
his testicles
so what's the administration planning to
do besides letting the men use women's
bathrooms well Biden has finalized new
plans to actually ramp up deportations
and require migrants to request Refugee
status in another country before
Crossing into the U.S and those who
don't are liable to be deported and
banished for five years now doesn't that
sound a bit familiar
yeah it's like Trump's policy which was
struck down in federal court and it was
one that Biden dragged him for at the
time the Dems called it racist cruel and
unnecessary of course now it's called
their approach right you jug eared freak
face we are taking this approach within
the constraints of a broken immigration
system that Congress has not fixed for
more than two decades and without the
resources we need Personnel facilities
transportation and others that we have
requested of Congress and that we were
not given who knew a pimple could talk
but do you know how much of a disaster
it must be for the Biden Administration
to start using the big bad orange racist
man's policies so why stop there why not
just get cracking on building the wall
then Joe can hire the guys who built the
one around his beach house and the one
between Hunter and his baby mama
because we know the border is still a
disaster border patrol averaged 8 700
daily migrant apprehensions over a
recent three-day period or as kgp would
say zero
hundreds of thousands are camped out of
the Border waiting for the right moment
to cross I should have bought stock in
tents
instead of Alec Baldwin's next Western
too soon or not soon enough hell it'll
look like the beginning of the New York
City marathon when the starter pistol is
fired thousands and thousands of young
men elbowing each other for better
position
but enough about the women's race
yeah yeah
the Guatemalan president told the Texas
Congressman that 80 000 migrants from
Venezuela are headed to the U.S and the
scary part is they're in a total of 11
vans
he called the White House about it but
it went straight into voicemail
perhaps they were too busy putting
classified documents in Biden's cage in
kcps
but at least it's not just border states
who bear the weight of the problem right
Democrat Mayors are dreading the many
more buses of migrants to their
Sanctuary cities for once reality calls
out their empty promises and I love it
apparently Manhattan May close large
sections of city streets for temporary
housing they'll be halting traffic to
help human traffic the reason streets
provide access to water sewer and
electricity as well as modular
prefabricated housing
holy
If Only They did that for the homeless
kill Mead wouldn't be sleeping on my
couch
the CEO of a tiny home manufacturing
says he may be supplying the units 420
square feet two bedroom foldable units
that can be deployed on site in New York
that's considered a castle
officials are also considering cruise
ships I hope Joe Mackey is the ship's
comedian they'll be fleeing back home in
no time
they agree
the city also wants to bus migrants to
The Burbs so now those counties are
declaring a state of emergency or even
worse at State of California
so it turns out solving America's
homeless crisis by adding millions of
new Homeless was a bad idea but now that
the crisis impacts everyone everyone's
waking up perhaps even very sleepy Joe
but he's got that wall around his house
so why should he care right Joe
no no no don't you could dare compare me
to the guy who came before me I'm My Own
man I get my own ideas
but it's just they're not sending their
best they're bringing drugs they're
bringing crime they're rapists and some
I assume are good people
I have a good brain I use the best words
I like people who weren't captured
and when the hell are we going to see
Obama's birth certificate
[Laughter]
period
let's welcome tonight's guest her
initials stand for killer triceps former
deputy National Security advisor kg Miss
barley
audiences hang on his every word so the
clubs banned rope comedian Joe Mackey
the last time she held a helium balloon
she landed in Memphis Fox News
contributor cartoon
and he hasn't needed a spotter since
2003 my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
so Joe uh this must anger you as
somebody who currently lives on the
street to see that people can just come
in here and get this modular housing
where you still live under that bridge
on 52nd Street Greg I don't live on the
street that was one week when I was
camping out for Phantom Menace tickets
it was disaster I got mono they call it
the kissing disease not in my case
but we're in big trouble now because the
only thing that's slowing down illegal
immigration is train derailments and you
can't count on that
I'll say this if if they can if they can
keep me out of a nightclub unless I
bring four ladies they can stop this
problem what they always want to change
it by saying we have to do stuff like
address the root causes and that's code
for saying a country that can't fix
Baltimore has to fix Honduras
foreign
excellent point Joe well done well done
KT what is you're the expert of National
Security and wearing purple
wow that was silent yeah I think I'm a
card he is more of a violet Greg oh is
it a violet okay all right you know I'm
is my cardinal colors yeah it's a card
how does this impact National Security
well what it does well for a couple of
reasons number one what it really does
is domestic security because what it
does is it's pitting every state and
every city against every other state if
I was in Tallahassee last week and
Florida's past legisl the toughest
anti-illegal immigration legislation in
the country and so there's it's now
class three felony if you transport
someone across the state lines into
Florida Florida's also got this huge
budget to take illegal immigrants and
bust them somewhere else right Island
Delaware Etc and even New York City is
trying to bus them into the suburbs and
the suburbs are saying no we don't want
them and they're going to bust them back
so other than the bus companies making a
lot of money
um I think this is no it's really the
worst thing that could happen to America
is when the states start fighting with
each other and that's what these idiots
have done the other thing is that the
body Administration they're great genius
right now here's their solution is that
you're going to go online if you want to
if you want to enter the United States
you go online you fill out a form and
you upload a photo of yourself have you
looked at those thousands of people
lined up who's got a cell phone nobody
has a cell phone and even if they had a
cell phone they don't have Wi-Fi
connection that's true or else it's wet
when they cross the river well that's
another issue unless you keep it in like
a little plastic bags that's what I do
yeah when I'm uh when you yeah well I
don't want to know where you're going
with yours and what kind of water hot
water you're in yeah they call me the
Swamp Thing
even when I'm on dry land hey you know
cat yeah these people are now getting
free tiny homes right so the tiny home
is bigger than your apartment yeah two
bedrooms
um and then they have the free food they
got the electricity they get everything
this must drive you crazy because you
work very hard and yet you have nothing
to show for it
it does feel like that sometimes
um but also the traffic probably not
going to be good for that either that's
true yeah I'm gonna be like actually one
of these would be more convenient for me
so I would just like to move in there
because
to be able to get to and from my
apartment because it's bad don't know if
as it is there's all the bike Lanes
there's the bus lanes with the bus has
like two people on it yeah and they get
all holes to themselves yeah it's the
whole bus Nobody Rides the Bus there's
like three people every time you see the
bus goes by there's like three people
sit on the bus and then there's those
outdoor dining Huts that homeless people
just pee in like nobody's eating like
nobody's eating in there so it's like at
what point like freedom of movement is a
human right and we do not have that in
New York City uh but yeah people on top
of that as we know the violence in the
subway nobody's taking the subway
anymore well I haven't heard good things
about it lately it happened come down to
the subway I'm surprised they haven't
done a PSA for it yet like subway it's
not that bad
because I haven't been on it in a long
time obviously unfortunately the root
causes is what needs to be done here
obviously title 42 it's ridiculous that
it lasted this long because covet has
not been an emergency for a very very
long time and regardless of how you feel
about this if it's a government abuse of
power you have to stand against it or
else you can never complain about other
girls abuses of power but yes I am gonna
I am very concerned about my commute all
right Tyrus uh it's kind of funny that
Joe once again is plagiarizing this time
he's he's been plagiarizing Trump after
he first still call him racist and then
he'll rip them off
it's not plagiarizing
it's just you know they're just Trading
people personalities like
Trump didn't commit crimes and accused
of crimes Biden commits crimes doesn't
get accused of crimes Trump has good
ideas now they're
Biden's bad are bad good ideas which
means they're now Trump's bad ideas like
well if they were good he would have put
him in when he was in well he did and
then you guys ended at the first day so
now they just changed the title it's
just like when you get a new car you
know whatever happened in that back seat
before you got it it's not your problem
right you know what I'm saying yes the
smells and all that that's from
something else it's different now it's
with you and that's the same thing
they're just you know another thing is
with this I think this is the time like
if I if I lived in New York I would be
getting Billboards showing beautiful
pictures of San Francisco in the 70s
yeah I'd be having the Riser like you
can go now Outdoors on a lovely Bell
card it's beautiful you know because San
Bernardino California I would be putting
all kinds of Places maps
and G and this treasure in the hills of
California I would start doing things
like that to get migrants maybe go that
way because we're going to see like
Kamala was right everybody loves buses
yeah apparently now so they're going to
drive people all over the country it's
really sad and the worst part is not
just like cats apartment being small you
work your butt off you buy your first
home
and you get a nice window and then you
wake up in the morning with your cup of
coffee and there's 14 new houses in your
front yard yeah
that's true using your hose yeah
[Applause]
it's so true all right we gotta move on
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else